la crise sanitaire a entraîné très
souvent une dégradation des conditions
de travail ou en tous les cas une
intensification des conditions de
travail avec ça il y a évidemment la
mise en place du télétravail pour les
travailleurs qui pouvait le faire et là
on se rend compte que cette mise en
place du télétravail
d'une certaine manière accentue cette ce
sentiment si vous voulez d'une
intensification ou d'une dégradation
le télétravail toujours encouragé donc
par le gouvernement malgré l'accalmie
sur le front du coc vide
le nouveau protocole sanitaire en
entreprise qui s'applique dès
aujourd'hui ne change pas la donne
télétravail et pour limiter les
contaminations kobe doit rester la norme
pour les salariés qui le peuvent alors
quel bilan peut-on tirer de cette
nouvelle façon de travailler qui s'est
imposé avec la pandémie est ce un
progrès ou au contraire une régression
pour celles et ceux qui ont dû s'y
mettre c'est notre rubrique l'édito avec
jacques sapir
[Musique]
bonsoir jacques la question donc du
télétravail qui a été au centre des
différends confinement que l'on a connu
sommes nous au début d'une nouvelle ère
où tout cela n'aura été qu'une grande
illusion finalement bonsoir c'est fini
alors oui effectivement le gouvernement
aimerait bien que le télétravail se
perpétue d'abord évidemment pour des
raisons sanitaires et puis aussi parce
que ça conforte d'une certaine manière
son image de la start up nation
après il est clair que les entreprises
l'année dernière avait vu ce
développement du télétravail avec un
certain optimisme
et elle avait même commencé à réduire
assez fortement la superficie des
bureaux qu'elle avait où qu elles louées
et puis est venu le retour du bâton et
est venu le jeudi rennes à la prise en
compte du fait que le bilan du
télétravail apparaît comme beaucoup plus
nuancé voire carrément négatif pour les
salariés mais aussi pour les entreprises
alors tout d'abord jacques combien de
salariés sont ils passés au télétravail
alors lors du premier confinement vous
savez le confinement de la fin mars 2020
jusqu'au début mais on estimé qu'il y
avait en moyenne environ 25% de
l'ensemble des salariés
c'est extrêmement important qui était
passé entre un télétravail tota
probablement 30 % si on regarde le
télétravail partiel et même 40%
si on considère les gens qui allaient
qui était au télétravail
un jour par semaine voire qui avait
travaillé quelques jours dans le mois
en télétravail ce chiffre retombe autour
de 10% de l'ensemble des salariés à
l'été 2020 puis avec le 2ème et le 3ème
confinement il remonte mais à 20% sert
pas du tout au niveau auquel il était
en mars mars avril 2020 et aujourd'hui
on est en train d'assister à un espèce
de d'effondrement du télétravail et
qu'est ce qui explique ces chiffres
alors il y as derrière ces chiffres
toute une série de raisons la première
chose qui est importante à comprendre
c'est que la crise sanitaire a entraîné
très souvent une dégradation des
conditions de travail ou en tous les cas
une intensification des conditions de
travail avec ça il y a évidemment la
mise en place du télétravail pour les
travailleurs qui pouvait le faire et là
on se rend compte que cette mise en
place du télétravail
d'une certaine manière accentue cette ce
sentiment si vous voulez d'une
intensification ou d'une dégradation
et puis surtout que si vous voulez ce
télétravail
eh bien il va entraîner une forte montée
des objectifs chiffrés des exigences
émotionnelles et puis de l'intensité de
la durée du travail
beaucoup de gens se plaignent
effectivement du fait que le télétravail
abouti à des horaires complètement
chamboulé ils sont obligés de travailler
le soir ou de travailler très tôt le
matin
donc tout cela constitue je dirais une
espèce de base de fond de la situation
des télétravailleurs
mais jackie est il une différence
notable entre les télétravailleurs et
les autres oui tout à fait tout à fait
alors on voit que 56% des gens qui sont
en télétravail disent que leur situation
a changé et s'est plutôt dégradée dans
la période de la crise sanitaire contre
44% pour les gens qui ne sont pas en
télétravail est par ailleurs au sein des
télétravailleurs donc là on ne regarde
que les gens qui sont en télétravail et
bien ces 33% qui considère qu' il ya eu
une intensification
un du travail et 14% qui considère qu'il
ya une dégradation des situations de
travail
par ailleurs il est clair que ceci a
entraîné un accroissement des inégalités
on voit très bien que ce sont les gens
qui hervé les cons les compétences les
plus faibles ou qui d'une certaine
manière et et je dirais le moins
appareiller pour faire du télétravail
qui se plaignent le plus mais il ya
aussi des femmes qui se plaignent le
plus et ça c'est un point important
parce que ça met le doigt sur les
conditions de travail
comprenez bien que télétravail et quand
on a des enfants à la maison quand on
doit garder justement ces enfants à la
maison
et bien c'est quelque chose qui est pas
du tout évident jacques à quoi est venue
alors il ya plusieurs il ya plusieurs
phénomènes ya tout d'abord la question
de la maîtrise des instruments
numériques
le fait que évidemment toute une série
de gens qui ont été obligés de passer au
télétravail avait une maîtrise moyenne
ou ou relativement faire il ya aussi le
fait que les connexions ou disons la
partie technique du système n'était pas
au point
alors que ce soit évidemment la vitesse
de transfert
la nature des ordinateurs dont on
pouvait disposer à la maison qui sont
souvent de moindre qualité que ce que
l'on pouvait avoir au bureau il ya aussi
les conditions générales de travail vous
savez ce n'est pas simple de transférer
un bureau chez soi alors c'est la
question de la superficie la question
des conditions de logement est ce que la
personne vit seule
ou est ce qu'elle vit en couple est ce
qu'elle vit sans enfant ou est ce
qu'elle vit avec des enfants bon c'est
l'ensemble de ces problèmes qui sont
venus pour constituer je dirais un
espèce de ressenti assez important du
fait que le télétravail entraîne une
dégradation de la situation de travail
la question qu'on peut se poser ce que
c'est lié à la durée du
travail oui oui on voit très bien que
dans les réponses à lenquête krakow café
la dares et bien il y à une montée de ce
genre de problème avec si vous voulez la
durée l'enquète krakow isole par exemple
des gens qui n'ont jamais été les
travailler des gens qui ont travaillé un
ou deux jours par mois
un jour par semaine et on voit que c'est
à partir de 3-4 jours par semaine que
les problèmes se posent en particulier
sur les questions de santé
on voit qui a très bien une espèce de
monter de la perception de douleur
physique par exemple le mal de dos et si
vous voulez quand on quand on est comme
ça courbet face à un ordinateur ou des
troubles du sommeil qui représente
aujourd'hui quelque chose d'assez
important d'ailleurs les troubles du
sommeil dans la population qui travaille
trois quatre jours par semaine
c'est le double de la proportion dans la
population qui ne travaillent jamais en
télétravail
cela veut donc dire que le télétravail a
eu des conséquences carrément néfastes
pour la santé
oui tout à fait et ça ça on peut le dire
alors il ya évidemment ces questions de
douleurs aux trains de douleurs
physiques ces questions de perturbation
du sommeil et alors ça touche évidemment
les gens qui se plaignent le plus de
l'intensification ou de la dégradation
comme on le voit sur le graphique
mais il ya aussi d'autres phénomènes ne
fait que les gens qui avaient des
compétences moyenne sont les premiers à
se plaindre du fait qu'ils avaient peu
de soutien que ce soit de leur
hiérarchie ou de leurs collègues
et ça c'est aussi visiblement un
ressenti qui a été très fort
la sensation d'isolement dans le
télétravail
en conclusion jacques le télétravail est
il un échec une voie sans issue
alors on peut peut-être pas parler
d'échec ou de voie sans issue comme tel
mais il est clair que le télétravail a
posé énormément de problèmes
je crois qu'il faut distinguer deux
situations
d'abord il ya des gens qui ont de très
fortes compétences qu'ils ont dit
une manière déjà l'habitude de se servir
des instruments numériques aussi des
gens qui sont de très bonnes situations
qui ont des grands appartements qu'ils
peuvent se permettre de faire garder
leurs enfants ou qui n'ont pas d'enfant
par ailleurs alors ces gens là qui
représente grosso modo 10 à 15 % des
gens qui sont passés en télétravail
autrement dit entre 1 et 1 et demi pour
cent entre 3 et 4 et demi pour s'en
excuser moi de l'ensemble des salariés
français
ces gens là ont plutôt apprécié le
télétravail mais pour le reste eh bien
on voit bien qu'il y a eu un sentiment
de dégradation et d'intensification un
sentiment aussi d'isolement de perte de
repères face à l'ensemble du collectif
de travail qui existait auparavant
au point que le retour au bureau qui a
été possible
depuis maintenant quelques semaines et
bien ce retour au bureau il est très
souvent vécue comme un soulagement voire
même comme une libération
par seth et les travailleurs voilà qui
donne donc à réfléchir parfois compte
les idées d'ailleurs préconçues merci et
jacques et à la semaine prochaine